To tap into the dopaminergic system,
you said you needed to value goal.
Is there any way to tap into the opioid
system?
I want to be more connected to people,
but part of me can't get myself to care.
Okay.
Well one of the things that that,
so maybe you're a little bit on the
disagreeable side,
that's a possibility.
There's some interesting clinical
evidence that suggests that one of the
things that disagreeable people can do
in order to facilitate their
interactions with other people is to do
people favorites.
And so what you might say is that you
could start by acting like you care and
then maybe you could learn how to care
through doing that.
So maybe you could say,
well,
I'm going to do something nice for
someone once every two days for a month
and,
and think about it a little bit and see
what,
see if that changes you.
Because you know,
sometimes you think yourself into change
and sometimes you act yourself into
changing your thoughts.
And so that's what I would start by
doing.
Um,
and you know,
you could also be more connected to
people regardless of whether you care,
you know,
let's say that it would take you six
months of practice or even a year of
practice.